jason has a rundown of everything
they've gone through in my archives
there's thousands of items in a storage
space that I pay for every month I would
say well over 90% of it has ended up in
the garbage pile per year isn't that
something that is fantastic so am I
paying less money every month this is
all on paper right now no one's actually
physically thrown anything away you're a
hoarder like you know everything became
super important because we had this idea
one day we'd have like a Howard Stern
museum but one point we took this crap
we said it has to be air conditioned
it's virtually numbered yes and
organized and meanwhile it's all gonna
go in the garbage now after years of
paying to archive it all there are three
things I have to ask you questions about
we don't know what to do with them if I
can throw them out all right go ahead
what are the three things the 1995 man
magazine issue with you on the cover
being plunged into the toilet I know Mad
Magazine is important to you is it the
actual real magazine this will be the
physical copy of the my physical copy
that we save I would listen okay I can't
save all of it Jason do you have Soupy
Sales comic book number one any Soupy
Sales Society member but I bought that
as a kid oh my god I wore that bus but
you don't [ __ ] it just throw out all the
stupid stuff there is something in your
archive that Jason I think are is
insanely valuable no we both would like
to have if you would let us have
somebody sent us a bunch of umbrellas
with the Howard fists logo on it I have
been searching for these umbrellas for
15 years because I lost Gary how many
umbrellas are there in there you two
this is gonna shock you but those
umbrellas are the most important thing
in that archive you two are welcome to
all umbrellas that you find in that
archive Howard I just left mine on a
train it was like the worst day of my
life anybody
it was awful I went in on this too I
don't think they deserve it well now
there'll be a fight in the office
two umbrellas is there anything else
that you question Jason well actually
just one think they don't know if it's
something from your childhood or not it
is a red egg with a wind-up green
Godzilla inside oh my god that looks
like something somebody must have sent
me and then it was just thrown right in
the archive it has nothing to do with me
I know it take that egg with dinosaur in
it and shove it up Ronnie's ass hey can
I ask if there was something in the
archive when Steve nawicki was a fan he
sent us like this weird diorama he like
researched the microphone and then
looked it up and painted the microphone
to make sure it was that microphone and
everything in the studio is exactly
where is Steve Steve what's wrong with
you how your set was in 2012 so the Noi
Minh TLM 103 was kind of sideways like
this ah and eventually in 2013 you had
an upside-down and then you had an
l-shaped adapter added on last year but
now you have a right-side-up adapter I'd
be very careful of being around him yeah
you're not coming over to my house Jason
don't throw out anything evidently all
this stuff is important
you